[Musik]
mussten sie wirklich wegen eines irrtums
sterben die auswertung der flugschreiber
soll klären ob eine iranische rakete das
flugzeug vom himmel holte
die grünen werden 40 ein kunterbuntes
linkes ökoprojekt mausert sich vom
bürgerschreck zur regierungspartei und
der klima protest und der siemens-chef
warum der weltkonzern in australien
probleme mit einem kohlegeschäft hat
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg genannt und willkommen
zum nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
zehnter januar norbert lehmann ist auch
dabei für den sport ein stück von mir
aus sicherheitsgründen hat die lufthansa
bis 20 januar alle flüge von und nach
teheran gestrichen immer mehr
regierungen gehen davon aus dass die
ukrainische passagiermaschine mit 176
menschen an bord tatsächlich von
iranischen raketen abgeschossen wurde
aus versehen iran weiß dass weiter
vehement zurück lässt aber jetzt
offenbar zu dass sich auch experten aus
den usa kanada und frankreich an den
ermittlungen beteiligen und von coaching
eine rakete steigt auf dann gibt es eine
explosion dieses amateurvideo soll den
abschuss der ukrainischen
passagiermaschine zeigen offenbar
zufällig gefilmt von einem augenzeugen
experten halten das video für echt iran
dagegen bezweifelt dass die echtheit der
aufnahmen können nicht verifiziert
werden zudem gebe es auch andere gründe
warum ein abschuss ausgeschlossen sei
unsere militärische luftabwehr arbeitet
eng zusammen mit der zivilen luft
überwachen die mitarbeiter beider
organisationen sitzen nebeneinander so
dass der abschuss einer
passagiermaschine absolut unmöglich ist
die geheimdienste der usa und anderer
länder allerdings gehen davon aus dass
das flugzeug abgeschossen wurde us
satelliten daten zeigen offenbar dass
der jet von einer iranischen rakete
getroffen wurde aus versehen heißt es
aus dem pentagon
und auch der kanadische premier sieht
darin einen möglichen grund für den
absturz
wir haben geheimdienstliche erkenntnisse
von diversen quellen von verbündeten und
auch unsere eigene diese erkenntnisse
deuten darauf hin dass das flugzeug von
einer iranischen boden luft rakete
abgeschossen wurde
das ist möglicherweise aus versehen
passiert
das iranische staatsfernsehen
veröffentlichte heute bilder vom
flugschreiber und dem stimmenrekorder
der unglücksmaschine
beide beschädigt aber die iranischen
ermittler sind optimistisch die daten
gemeinsam mit amerikanischen experten
auswerten zu können
dann könnte abschließend geklärt werden
ob das flugzeug tatsächlich
außen wurde und solange das nicht klar
ist fliegt die lufthansa nicht nach
teheran
für die kommenden zehn tage sind alle
flüge nach iran gestrichen
aus sicherheitsgründen wie die lufthansa
heute mitteilte auch nach überzeugung
mehrere eu mitglieder ist der absturz
der passagiermaschine wohl ein
tragischer irrtum in folge des konflikts
zwischen den usa und iran
die eu sieht sich in der rolle des
vermittlers vom sondertreffen der
außenminister in brüssel berichtet
stefan leifert das jahr ist erst zehn
tage jung doch für europas außenminister
muss es sich viel älter anfühlen drei
krisentreffen in vier tagen die
flugzeugkatastrophe nun die letzte
wendung der iran krise es muss alles
lückenlos aufgeklärt werden die
verantwortlichkeiten müssen geklärt
werden
es darf nichts unter den tisch gekehrt
werden denn wenn das der fall wäre wäre
das der nährboden für neues misstrauen
und das ist das letzte was wir zur zeit
brauchen
seit tagen sucht die eu nach ihrer rolle
im iran-konflikt europas chefdiplomaten
wollen zurück auf die weltbühne und
nicht nur zuschauer sein
im konflikt zwischen washington und
teheran nicht zum verhandlungstisch
wollen dann bringen wir den
verhandlungstisch zu ihnen
europa könnte gute dienste anbieten und
sozusagen zwischen versuchen wieder
einen politischen prozess und warum geht
es zwischen der von washington in gang
bringen für europa steht viel auf dem
spiel in dieser krise vor allem das atom
abkommen mit iran
dass der us-präsident die eu und zur
kündigung des historischen deals
auffordert stößt in brüssel sauer auf
wer als europäer stehen zu diesem atom
vertrag
wir sind nicht ermahnung wie der
amerikanische präsident dass das so
zerschlagen werde
wir haben uns 13 jahre 13 lange jahre
wir uns eingebracht die eu will wieder
weltpolitik fähig werden so der anspruch
in brüssel mit der iran krise kommt die
gelegenheit dafür schneller als ihr lieb
ist
vor zwei tagen hatte us-präsident schon
angekündigt jetzt sind die details klar
us-außenminister pompeo gab die neuen
wirtschaftssanktionen gegen iran bekannt
die strafmassnahmen betreffen unter
anderem den stahlsektor des landes
außerdem werden hochrangige vertreter
irans mit sanktionen belegt vom konflikt
mit iran ist auch das nachbarland irak
direkt betroffen die lage ist explosiv
politik und milizen im land werden von
teheran gesteuert tausende soldaten aus
dem westen sollen die demokratie
stabilisieren
der tödliche drohnenangriff der
amerikaner auf den iranischen general in
bagdad hat die menschen auf gehüllt doch
es sind nicht nur die usa die wut auf
sich ziehen
liga ist für uns in bagdad bagdad sadr
city erstes freitagsgebet seit dem
angriff auf den iranischen general
suleiman ii hier in sadr city waren sie
schon immer gegen die amerikanische
militärpräsenz üblich fast sind rufe wie
tod amerika neu aber ist die distanz zu
iran iran ist ein freundliches land aber
wir sind nicht ihre sklaven und sie
sollten uns nicht als solche behandeln
es ist der alles beherrschende einfluss
teherans der nun schiiten wie in sadr
city
probleme macht fast nur alte beim gebiet
[Musik]
die jugend aus der city demonstrieren in
bagdad auf dem tahrir platz mit
andersgläubigen gegen korruption die
wirtschaftliche ausbeutung die
unterdrückung durch den iran seit
monaten schon
hunderte demonstranten wurden von
schiitischen milizen umgebracht
gesteuert aus teheran das seinen
einfluss im irak erhalten will sagen
hier viele
wir lehnen die einmischung durch den
iran ab wir fordern unabhängigkeit
niemand davon seinen willen auf diese
worte sind vorsichtig gewählt ohne
kamera wird die wut auf iran grenzenlos
viele demonstranten machen den iran
verantwortlich für korruption
misswirtschaft ausbeutung die amerikaner
so heißt es hier dürft nicht abziehen
sonst würde der irak von iran
langfristig in gänze übernommen
solche sympathie für amerika ist hier
neu in teheran wird man das nicht gern
hören nach deutschland gute nachrichten
für mehr als fünf millionen bahncard
nutzer die preise fallen um rund 10%
bund und länder einigten sich darauf wie
im klimapaket vorgesehen die
mehrwertsteuer für die bahncard 25 und
50 abzusenken heißt die bahncard 50 für
die zweite klasse kostet künftig 229
euro für 555 70 gibt es die bahncard 25
ein lange streit in der großen koalition
scheint beendet union und spd sehen die
grundrente für geringverdiener auf der
zielgeraden kanzleramtsminister braun
cdu sagte es gehe nur noch um die
technische umsetzung nach ende der
spd-klausurtagung zeigte sich auch
fraktionschef mützenich zuversichtlich
dass die grundrente komme profitieren
soll wer jahrzehntelang beiträge
eingezahlt hat aber bisher nur eine
schmale rente bekommt sie wollten eine
alternative zu den herkömmlichen
parteien seien mit diesem anspruch
gründeten sich vor 40 jahren in
karlsruhe die grünen geradezu ein
kulturschock war die partei für
deutschland streit vor nicht nur nach
außen auch intern krachte es von anfang
an
zu den verschiedenen strömungen gesellte
sich 1993 dann auch noch die bürger ddr
bürgerrechtsbewegung bündnis 90 heute
ist sich die partei einiger denn je vom
bürgerschreck zum begehrten
koalitionspartner patricia wiedemeier
und andreas huppert
das war ein bundespräsident zur
geburtstagsparty der grünen kommt und
dann auch noch redet vor 40 jahren
undenkbar heute ist es realität
angekommen im politischen establishment
sind die ehemaligen öko und friedens
revoluzzer längst die grünen haben das
land verändert das land hat die grünen
verändert
deutschland ist ohne zweifel offener
geworden vielfältiger menschlicher und
moderner in diesen letzten 40 jahren
verändert haben dass die grünen mit
ihrem kampf für umweltschutz und gegen
atomkraft ein sammelbecken
unterschiedlichster gruppen
friedensaktivisten kommunisten christen
und minister innen die politik die sie
machen wollten nannten sie grüne politik
einer der genialsten akte war
wahrscheinlich diesen farb namen für
diese partei zu wählen weil das stimmt
ja immer noch in der protestpartei bird
joschka fischer zum polit popstar die
grünen zur regierungspartei in hessen
1983 gelingt der einzug in den bundestag
nach der wende vereinigen sich ost und
west grüne zu bündnis 90 die grünen mit
der zeit steigen auch die politischen
machtansprüche die zeit wo wir im
wesentlichen protestpartei waren so
wichtig sie war diese zeit ist mit der
deutschen einheit endgültig zu ende
gegangen
1998 werden die grünen juniorpartner
unter kanzler schröder
der bundeswehreinsatz im kosovo sorgt
jedoch für heftige richtungs und
flügelkämpfe real muss gegen fundis
heute ist von diesem revoluzzer geist
nichts mehr zu spüren
natürlich
gesellschaft uns verändert und ich
glaube das ist auch gut so weil alles
andere würde stillstand bedeuten
die party ist geeint in ihrem willen zur
macht keine flügelkämpfe mehr keine
linken parolen zum umsturz der
gesellschaft anders als vor 40 jahren
nach australien dort haben starke winde
aus zwei der zahlreichen brände einen
großbrand gemacht 240.000 menschen
wurden per sms alarmiert sich in
sicherheit zu bringen
die rufe aus der bevölkerung nach mehr
klimaschutz werden derweil lauter in
sydney und melbourne gingen zehntausende
auf die straße
sie fordern von konya minister morrison
unter anderem den massiven australischen
kohle export zurückzufahren
ein riesiges neues kohlebergwerk in
australien bringt auch siemens in
bedrängnis klimaschützer protestierten
heute dagegen dass der konzern das zug
signalsystem dafür liefern will siemens
chef joe kaeser hatte schon vorher
versprochen den millionenauftrag noch
mal zu prüfen
nach einem treffen mit fridays for
future aktivistin luisa neubauer
versprach er bis montag zu entscheiden
und überraschte sie mit einem jobangebot
romanesco war proteste heute gleich in
mehreren deutschen städten ob vor der
siemens zentrale in münchen oder der
australischen botschaft in wellen
empörung überall zu hören die wälder
brennen in australien gleichzeitig wird
dort ein kohle großprojekt geplant
beteiligt der siemens konzern
das ist natürlich schockierend dass in
australien jetzt noch ein kohlebergwerk
aufmachen soll das bis zu 60 millionen
tonnen kohle fördern kann im jahr wir
sind hier auch um siemens aufzufordern
zu sagen ihr könnt so ein projekt nicht
unterstützen australien besitzt riesige
kohlevorkommen mit dem neuen großprojekt
sollen tausende neue arbeitsplätze
entstehen
der protest dagegen läuft vor ort schon
länger siemens soll sicherheitstechnik
für eine bahnstrecke liefern
nach dem gespräch heute mit den freitags
fünf user aktivisten kündigt der
vorstandschef an das projekt zu
überdenken
egal mit welcher zeit bekommen werden
wir sehen dass wir im unternehmen das
thema nachhaltigkeit auch bei indirekten
beteiligungen an kritischen projekten
künftig besser verstehen und
frühzeitiger frühzeitig erkennen müssen
die umweltaktivisten wollen im nachgang
keine gemeinsamen bilder mit siemens
äußern sich unzufrieden dass die männer
überlegt hilft dem klima original gar
nichts was wir brauchen es siemens und
joe kaeser die handeln der freude ist
for future aktivistin boote siemens-chef
derweil einen sitz in einem
aufsichtsgremium an das angebot wollte
die klimaschützer rinn hinterher nicht
kommentieren
klein aber mit bewegter geschichte vor
genau 100 jahren wurde das saarland
gegründet und hat seither mehrfach die
nationalität gewechselt nach dem ersten
weltkrieg stellen die versailler
verträge das gebiet unter französische
verwaltung 1935 entscheiden die
saarländer
sie wollen ins deutsche reich nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg steht das land wieder
unter französischem einfluss 1955 noch
mal eine volksbefragung und schließlich
der anschluss an die bundesrepublik
susanne freitag
das war das erste saarländische
nummerschild für unsere autos dann kam
das hier
und das war das letzte bevor wir zur
bundesrepublik kommen noch öfter als das
autokennzeichen hat werner weiter den
pass gewechselt er ist 94 sein freund
horst schnabel ist anfang 70 und hat
eine sammlung von saarland schätzen im
keller ihre heimat ständig hin und her
gerissen 1920 kapitel der versailler
vertrag das saargebiet von deutschland
ab frankreich kontrollierte militärisch
und hatte als kriegs entschädigung
zugriff auf die saar kohle 1935
volksentscheid für eine rückkehr ins
deutsche reich
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg wurde das
saarland ein eigener staat mit
nationalelf sogar 1954
qualifikationsspiel saarland gegen
deutschland das saarland verloren
1955 dann wieder eine volksabstimmung
das saarland wird deutsch
das hat familien zerrissen während mein
großvater auf der einen seite war
väterlicherseits war das dann bei meinem
vater selbst schon noch mal anders
wahrgenommen und das hat man gespürt
dass da was bis in die familien bis auf
kleine kinder hinein auch zu
zerrissenheit geführt hat aus berlin ist
die französische botschafterin angereist
und außenminister heiko maas kam direkt
aus brüssel nach saarbrücken
auch seine oma hatte mehrere pässe und
jetzt feiern sie runden geburtstag ein
jahrhundert
den deutschen handballer feiern dass die
erste hürde für die gestern abend
souveräner sieg gegen die niederlande
aber morgen abend da geht es dann so
richtig zur sache
im spiel gegen europameister spanien
alle 16 deutschen spieler sind fit fürs
erste em topspiel bundestrainer prokop
fordert vom team viel konzentration und
mut konzentrieren mussten sich die
deutschen handballer bereits heute gegen
eine analyse vor dem wichtigen
vorrundenspiel gegen spanien
qualifizieren sich beide nämlich für die
hauptrunde werden sie ihre punkte aus
diesem spiel
dorthin mitnehmen mut braucht die
mannschaft von bundestrainer christian
prokop auch um ein mittel gegen die
starke defensive der spanier zu finden
die chancenverwertung war im spiel gegen
die niederlande noch ausbaufähig haben
uns morgen was zurecht gelegt und das
wollen wir voll nutzen wollen voll
angreifen und selbst den fehler
entstehen ist es da wichtig als team
zusammen zu halten
für den nötigen rückhalt sollen morgen
die deutschen torleute sorgen
andreas wolf und jogi bitter schon
gestern glänzend in form könnten mit
solchen paraden den grundstein legen für
einen sieg zweiter deutscher biathlon
erfolg beim weltcup in oberhof gestern
denise herrmann auf platz 2 heute
johannes kühn auf platz drei im sprint
über zehn kilometer vom üblichen
oberhofer schmuddelwetter zum weltcup
ließen sich die etwa 15.000 zuschauern
war die stimmung nicht vermiesen
dafür sorgte vor allem johannes kühn
hervorragender dritter platz wir helfen
ja aber manchmal kann dann ist das
natürlich schreit schneller schneller
und wenn du deine konstant es hat
einfach nicht an peiffer komplettierte
mit rang sieben nach einem überstandenen
infekt das gute deutsche ergebnis
wir wollen hat martin fourcade zwar in
abwesenheit des norwegischen
seriensiegers johannes b aber auch weil
er alle zehn scheiben traf und das
wasser noch schon von mir dankeschön zum
wochenende zeigt sich auch die sonne
wieder öfter mehr dazu hat gleich erst
intern das heute journal gegen 23 uhr 10
mit marietta slomka machen sie sich noch
einen schönen freitagabend danke für ihr
interesse und bis morgen wenn sie mögen
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter wir haben zwar
winter aber das wetter hält sich nicht
dran von westen her kommen immer noch zu
milde luftmassen das einzige was sich
ändert ist dass die tiefs allmählich
abziehen und ein hoch setzt sich durch
es gibt also ein bisschen mehr
sonnenschein aber auch das risiko für
nebel steigt ebenfalls schauen wir in
die nacht da gibt es noch den letzten
regen der abzieht dann klart es auf es
kann zu überfrierenden nässe kommen also
glatte straßen ganz im westen bildet
sich nebel sonst ist auch mal
sternenklarer himmel dabei mit
temperaturen von minus 1 grad in der
eifel und in schleswig-holstein 5 grad
an der ostsee ja morgen im tagesverlauf
im süden auch sonnige abschnitte auch
nach norden hin in der norddeutschen
tiefebene stürmische böen an der nordsee
aus südwest durchaus dabei und die
temperaturen dazu zwei grad im vogtland
und 8 grad im südwesten deutschlands die
temperaturen sind also mittlerweile
einstellig die nächsten tage am sonntag
im norden regen ansonsten ruhiges wetter
bei null bis neun grad ja und der
nächste regen erreichte uns dann zum
dienstag und dann wird sogar wieder
milder bis 12 grad
damit ein schöner abend